greetings everyone this is rob sanders
with simply learn thank you for joining
and today we're going to cover search
engine optimization interview questions
and answers so thanks for joining again
and here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible we're going to
go through a series of questions and i'm
going to answer those questions for you
okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you take in or listen
to my seo courses on youtube for seo we
we talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put i mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site b
we're gonna basically tell google bing
and some of these other search engines
hey go ahead and follow that link now i
know file is just the opposite so no
follow link doesn't allow the search
engine crawlers to follow it so if we
have a link on our site
site a pointing to site b
we can put a nofollow tag in there and
what that's going to do it's going to
signal to the crawlers hey don't follow
this link so
in the end if the crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice passed and so google is
not going to give you credit or give
that site credit for having a link
pointing to it or pointing to another
site or from another site and so it's
all about linking so we can control if
there's links on our site whether we
want the crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow tags so just a
reminder link jews is the reputation of
equity passed from one website to
another so if you have a link on another
website and that website is of high
quality meaning their page authority
their domain authority is high they have
a lot of content you know they're not
spammy they're really rich and they're
relevant then you may want to make sure
that the link pointing from that site to
your site is a nofollow so that way that
google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is going to be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
no follow and why would we do a
no-follow well it depends it really
depends a lot of social media platforms
like facebook have no follows if you
have a lot of content you may not want
to be pushing out a lot of do follows it
could actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice onto and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an seo perspective if i have a site
and i have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites i'm
going to be particular about who i allow
the search engine to follow and what
links i allow not to follow so here's an
example of what they look like so do
follow is simply just the href notice
the nofollow has the the tag appended to
it the href tag with a nofollow so if
the search engine is crawling your site
and they see that no follow there
they're not going to follow that link
and vice versa if there's a link on
another site pointing to yours and
there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so
301 redirects tell users and the search
engine specifically that an original
page has been moved and this is the
keyword here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so if we
don't have a page anymore we have a new
page let's just say you built a new
website with new urls you want to make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page with a 301 redirect so if a 301
redirect is permanent then a 302 is
temporary so we want the search engines
to
recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
google to
not keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they may remove both pages from its
index okay but if we have something
permanent in place google may say okay
this page is permanently linking to
another page or redirecting to another
page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page in the index and eventually remove
the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in google search index
and we get it sometimes pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in seo
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from quite quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are gonna
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just gonna build our credibility
it's gonna increase increase our domain
authority and then the net effect of
that is if we're credible and we have
high domain authority then that's going
to increase the rankings of our pages
and when the pages increase in ranking
then we're going to get more of a lion's
share of the traffic for certain
keywords that our pages are found for
and if our pages are found and getting
traffic then because we have increased
rankings we're likely going to have
increased traffic and then it's just a
snowball effect so more traffic leads to
more engagement and conversions so the
whole idea for seo is remember you have
an on-page strategy and an off-page
strategy building external links is part
of an off-page seo strategy and we want
to make sure that you know we are
relevant in the form of a link or in the
form of content on other high quality
sites being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
domain authority google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on youtube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with seo because videos are
found youtube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on youtube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so
make sure you go ahead and follow the
best practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty i.e low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on twitter or facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant that's going
to grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with twitter and
facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtagging
and then this goes about saying you did
all the work created a really great
video
it's engaging it's informative you
optimized it feel free to promote your
video on other social media platforms
okay don't just stick with youtube per
se
so the benefit here is if you post it on
facebook or linkedin or whatever
platform of your choice and it gets
engagement people click on the link go
to youtube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're gonna see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so
promote your videos to help you with the
ranking of the video on youtube so that
does play into it so go ahead and
promote it so other people can watch it
like it comment etc and that's going to
engage other people to want to do the
same so what is mobile first indexing
this is a really important and timely
question mobile first indexing means
google's just using mobile friendly
content for indexing and ranking
websites so in other words google for
example has two bots they have the
traditional desktop bot and they have a
smartphone bot and eventually everybody
that has a website is going to be
migrated over to the smartphone bot and
so with that smartphone bot goes to your
website and starts crawling what do you
think they're looking for their
smartphone bot they're looking for
mobile friendly content if it's not
mobile friendly meaning the page isn't
designed for a smartphone browser or
let's just say the images are way too
large or you have to expand the text
just to read it you know a lot of these
these issues that somebody would have
just simply trying to read something on
a web page on their mobile device
google's not going to grab that content
so you want to make sure it's mobile
friendly so it gets indexed and so if
your website has a responsive design
google will rank your website based on
its performance on mobile devices okay
so you want to make sure that your
website is mobile friendly and if you're
in an interview and somebody asked this
question you could even take it a step
further and say look i'm going to
measure how friendly my wall my website
is for mobile devices in google search
console because google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but i
can tell you if i'm google and i'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bop and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly i'm probably not
gonna index it or rank it so you want to
leverage that report in google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
google search consoles
mobile usability report okay number six
list down the most important local seo
ranking factors okay so organic local
ranking is just as important as anything
else in organic search because if you
have a local business you want to use
the likes of say google my business to
show up when somebody types in you know
looking for a florist or
you're looking for a coffee shop so what
you want to do is you want to create a
web page for every product and service
okay you also want to opt for your
business listings on google my business
and and there are plenty of other local
business directories out there like yelp
for example or bing even has one so go
ahead and also make sure you have a
business listing as well but since
google in the united states has a huge
market share you want to start with
google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so
you want to make sure that that's
current and consistent so if you have a
number on your website make sure it's
the same number on google my business
okay you can embed a google map on your
website you could certainly optimize the
meta tags and content not only on your
web pages but within your google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
i mentioned yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews the hat you
have the better off you are okay so i
always say this with the uh with local
search three of the main factors in
showing up for local search on say
google is obviously the keyword the
second is the proximity of where that
person is and then third is the reviews
so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
google my business okay so working in
those keywords making sure your your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading
your the the business out on other
directors that's really all these are
really key factors for local seo okay so
question number seven how to avoid
duplicate content getting penalized for
duplicate content so for example if you
have two different versions of a web
page you may result in a duplicate
content issue so it's just seo 101 you
never want to have two two or more pages
with the same content so what do we do
well we can avoid this in having google
penalize us by again setting up a 301
redirect remember three or ones are
permanent we can also use what they call
canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and the third option is opt for
preferred domain in google search
console okay so if you have multiple no
names make sure you set up a primary one
in search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three i would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's going
to sit on the page it's going to alert
google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are gonna have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell search engines hey this
is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what i mean
by simple as possible really i mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images in other words don't have such a
large image size if you don't need
something very large don't have it okay
you want to improve server response time
what do we mean by that well your site's
sitting on a server somewhere you could
own that server or you can be renting it
out from say amazon web services or
let's just say godaddy as your registrar
they also have web hosting well if you
have it on say godaddy's server you may
be sharing that server with other
businesses and at certain times of the
day other businesses may get a lot of
traffic and suck up a lot of bandwidth
what is that going to do that's going to
reduce the server response time for your
site and so you want to make sure you
have an idea of you know what server
your web page your website is on and you
want to be able to can have some control
over that because if your server
response is slow that's going to slow
down everything else in terms of loading
in the browser and that's not going to
be good for seo okay optimize your code
what do you mean by optimize mimifying
when we see mimifying we mean get rid of
some of the redundant code if you have
css you know get rid of chop some of the
get rid of the javascript you're not
using so that's what we mean by
optimizing code reduce redirects okay
ideally you just want to have one
redirect in place you don't want to
create a daisy chain so to speak of
redirecting and redirecting after that
that's never going to bode well and it's
going to slow things down as well enable
browser caching so if you enable browser
caching basically if somebody comes back
to the page they've been on say two days
ago they're probably gonna see a cash
version of that page and then off for
the content delivery network as well so
these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just google page speed insights or even
just something generic like google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
pagespeed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a url when you plug
in the url google is going to analyze
the url for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see google gives a
score so we could see the score from
mobile and we could see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here i could see
some of the issues that the site may be
having in terms of page load time for
their desktop if i flip over to mobile
you know here i can see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
anywhere you can just always google it
as well uh here you got to reduce the
impact of third-party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduced
javascript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
met about coding okay so sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should will tend to slow down
the site okay so you can use pagespeed
insights you can always get a glimpse of
how pages are loading simply by also
going to for example google analytics
under behavior okay you can go to site
speed and if you click on overview okay
google what google does is they do a
sampling of pages over time and in this
case based on 89 page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific pages
load your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
google analytics to get a sense of how
quick your pages are loading now
there are certain factors that do affect
load time so obviously the way the page
is built with the code the images etc
but also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be
in the united states and have worse
network service than you do say in
you know
ivory coast in africa okay so it really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and google analytics
you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools at your disposal one
google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here
so when should an individual target
short tail and long tail keywords okay
so
remember short tail are usually one to
two keywords very broad in nature long
tail keywords maybe three four keywords
in a query or maybe an entire sentence
those are considered long tail keywords
so usually short tail keywords have
higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower
uh volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about long tail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague or broad in nature
long tail keywords are used for targeted
pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name
you could certainly optimize that page
for that product name again the product
name may have low volume but if somebody
types in exactly that product name you
show up the chance of you them
converting are going to be very high so
you don't have to always be that
specific with the product name but try
and be as specific as you possibly can
in order to get somebody to click on
your link in the search engine results
and get them over to your site to
convert okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just honed in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are they port elements to
focus while developing a website so
we're talking in terms of seo okay so if
somebody asks me this question in an
interview what am i going to focus on
while developing a website well the
answers are right here yes we talked
about mobile mobile is so important
because a lot of websites are going to
be
indexed with google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture and navigation we want to
have a simple url structure okay no
overly cumbersome the navigation should
simply be clean and neat okay if you
have five products okay maybe
you have uh in your navigation you have
something called products with all five
listed or you have all five products in
the main navigation the key is you just
wanna make it clean and neat easy for
somebody to find the the rule of thumb
is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for google but
if complicated for the end user it's
probably going to be complicated for
google you always want to create a site
map now what is that sitemap a sitemap
is simply just a formatted file with to
that includes all your urls and assets
your images and your videos they're
going to be sitting on your server as
well so you want google or these these
bots to be able to find your pages and
assets and by the way you want to take
it a step further and make sure you
upload that site map which is sitting in
the root directory meaning domain.com
sitemap.xml
okay you want to take that site map and
make sure you input that site map
location in google search console that
way google search console has a one-way
ticket to grab the elements in the
sitemap another important element to
focus on while developing a website is
having a robot's text file and all a
robot's text file is it's like a lock i
always say to a house so if you lock a
door in your house nobody's gonna be
able to get in that door so it's all a
robot's text file is you're telling
google and these other bots that are
coming across your site what's locked
and what's not logged meaning what they
have access to what they don't have
access to so you want to be able to make
sure you have a robot's text file if
you're trying to not index specific
pages of your website because if you
tell google don't crawl these pages or
this directory they're not going to get
crawled if they don't get crawled
they're not going to get indexed so
robots text file is an important element
to focus on
while you're developing your website and
while you're developing your website it
could be on a you know in a directory
just called new website so you probably
want to have new website as the
directory in the robots text file and
just to let google know don't go into
this directory because it's my new
website i'm not ready to go live yet so
you don't want it indexed so
there's a lot of reasons to have robots
text files that's the main reason
map you want google to get these pages
and assets quickly okay you want to make
sure that your site architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when i say content i don't necessarily
just mean words i also mean videos i
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if if an end user finds your site
engaging google is likely going to find
your site engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just to recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so the bots can easily access
and mix the content okay with a
responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your site's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where they
located along with the videos and images
okay and then the robot's text just
instructs the search engine crawlers to
understand what pages should not be
indexed okay this is simply just a text
file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house
then give it that way if you have any
questions feel free to visit us at
simplylearn.com i want to thank you for
hanging in there and good luck and we'll
see you on the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here